[Music]
[Applause]
I'm mark Barnard and I am by myself
because keV is Kevin it in the world is
as a Weight Watchers ambassador I think
he's in Dubai right now I'm not sure
spreading the wealth to the masses
yeah he's off doing keV stuff and so I'm
here still in Los Angeles I'm here by
myself and the scum and villainy Cantina
which I love being in an empty bar I
also love being in a full bar but
there's something kind of you know
degenerate chic about being in an empty
bar by yourself in the middle of the day
that's exactly where I am because I'm a
degenerate and I'm chic but we are here
today to talk about Avengers infinity
war which I have seen in the way that
we've all seen because we're all nerds
and was trying to figure out when and
how and where I'm gonna be able to talk
about my thoughts on it so we decided
let's just descend on the scum and
villainy Cantina and let's just get this
done so we're here to get it done I will
say this the first time I saw this movie
was at the end of a 31 hour marathon at
the El Capitan Theatre in Los Angeles
you're on Hollywood Boulevard there was
12 movies culminating in Avengers
infinity war I will I can't lie to you
and say that I wasn't compromised
mentally and physically by 31 hours in a
movie theater without magic reclining
seats and without people bringing you
food and beverage on tiny tables and and
catering to your every need know they're
suppose this is a bit of a if there is a
such thing as a movie watching marathon
the kind that makes your nipples bleed
that's what this was
[Music]
29 hours 29 [ __ ] hours and that
whoever you are if you pray for me it's
Oh
[Music]
and there's a dude in it and a bike
helmet lookie I said make it
just finished Ironman having a five
minute break between
no hope
go back in the theater because I got
look I got this fancy ass
which lets me go in
well as I please on old-timers
7:45 maybe almost a decline
I feel pretty good I think you know
chick-fil-a will help we just finished
the words so there's three movies down
alright so that was Captain America the
First Avenger it is 10:30 something I
would say yeah it's after 1:00 a.m. I
just finished Avengers which of all of
them that I've seen it's a melon the
most 320 320 halfway through according
to this thing alright so I'm here
outside what's your name
I'm Brian Brian hi so we are both doing
this stupid [ __ ] marathon that you
apparently didn't know about until you
caught way was the FIR I was afraid
there wouldn't be one after Thor didn't
have it's marathon oh I've been to an
event Uehara
Braverman slept at all no I'm trying
that too and in the last time you're
gonna buy all the [ __ ] way through I
just keep buying in Oz you are such a
street racer man you really are I never
get to
[Laughter]
okay so it's 601 Pam still haven't
really slept but what are you gonna do
we have no options
this is what we signed up for this is
the job as Kathleen said yeah so just
finish Doctor Strange that happened that
is nine down three to go
six and a half hours until we get to see
forgetting infinitely large circles
[Music]
we just finished watching spider-man
homecoming
so now how are you holding up how how's
your spine doing he's doing it oh man I
come out for a little bit of an airbrake
after the last four movies because my
back and my knees are aching I think I
called my second wind we're going in the
back
black naphtha that's gonna rejuvenate
the entire crowd and then before you
know it it's gonna be infinity word that
it's gonna be on it's gonna be on is
gonna be pay dirt finally lovin movies
servant
ours are the same
it's done 31 hours in that theater over
there
goddammit idea honey I had a wonderful
time I met some lovely people and yeah I
feel like I should get some kind of
medal for that endurance test but by the
time I sat through Iron Man and The
Incredible Hulk and Captain America
First Avenger and Thor and Avengers and
Avengers age of Ultron and Civil War and
got into the galaxy and Doctor Strange
and spider-man homecoming and black
panther by the time we get to Avengers
infinity war your brain is kind of mushy
and a little bit doughy and you are also
physically mushy in a little bit doughy
so I was not quite at my at my at my
finest for that moment but I and then I
saw it again a couple days later after
you know being able to put my body back
together bionic man style and you know I
the first experience in seeing it we
were all in that theater just so
frigging jazzed for it
it was it was a wonderful experience
even though I missed half the movie
because so many who's in hollers and
cheers and and all that stuff by the
time I would been able to sit down and
focus on it it is a it is first and
foremost a impossibility that this movie
even exists at all the fact that they
were able to connect these threads and
weave these this these strands of
various story over the 18 movies that
exist in the MCU you know and make it
feel as if a like a cohesive whole able
to give every character a moment able to
give every sort of relationship a little
room to breathe and able to put 30 movie
stars on screen in the same film is is a
monumental task and all parties
concerned should just be like back
patting themselves because it should not
exist this is it's it's it's remarkable
that it is I said all and the fact that
it coheres as a story is also somewhat
impossible given all of those things you
need to to feed into but and I was a
little bit
kind of teed up for this by I went to
the Avengers junk and I got to interview
the writers and they told me that the
main character of this movie is Thanos
and they were able to decide who gets
the most shine who gets the most light
in this film by how they intersected
with fan OHS and so that for me was that
was the key for unlocking the process
for them writing it and it was the key
for me and unlocking the process while
watching it because the first like 40
minutes of this movie are kind of
emotionally distant because you're not
spending any real time with the
characters that you've come to know and
love you're spending you know a little
bit of time with Doctor Strange and Wong
and and this Bruce Banner and then that
Keys you into into Tony Stark and pepper
and then you're kind of bouncing in to
Scotland and you're seeing vision and
Scarlet Witch and but you're not really
in any of those stories those stories
are not what it's about it's about
fanouts in his quest for the gems and it
takes a little while for you to kind of
calibrate your mind to that and you know
the the good stories every story teaches
you how to ingest it as it goes like the
wire is was fundamentally unlike any
other TV show that came before it and it
was a little off-putting at first but it
teaches you how to roll with it like the
narrative part of narratives job is to
teach you how to ingest the narrative
you know Shakespeare is meant to be
heard and not read and when you hear it
it makes sense in a way that it doesn't
on the page and I feel like once you
start to live in the rhythms of infinity
war it starts to make more sense you
start to realize that no we're following
foul knows it's Thanos his quest
it's his narrative that we're watching
and and so the emotional core of this
movie is about fan OHS and it's not
about our heroes and so that took a
little while to kind of get used to but
I always if this movie kind of felt
myself at a little bit of like an
emotional distance because you know and
weird by the way we're gonna spoil some
[ __ ] I mean it's been a week it's been
longer than that who knows when you're
gonna get to watch this but if you
haven't seen it by now I don't know what
you're waiting for other than maybe like
infirmity or something
but given the box office the the highest
opening movie of all time the most
mystic weekend the it smashed almost
every record and every expectation as it
went along the way but we're gonna spoil
some stuff you know that what this movie
is fundamentally about is Thanos putting
together his magic gauntlet and
disappearing half of the cosmos you know
killing half of everybody in order to
make balance and to do so he's got to
give up the thing that he loves the most
which we're being told as Gamora and
then to stop him the plan to stop in
which we never get the totality of but
it hinges upon
[Music]
everybody dying but also star-lord chris
pratt's
Peter quill not [ __ ] up that plan
which he does in grand fashion so much
of that idea the whole idea that you
know all of the space Avengers have to
deal with Thanos on the planet Titan and
the plan is going incredibly well that
they've managed to confuse him and tie
him down and then mantas is on his head
and she's putting him to sleep and they
all they have to do is pull the gauntlet
off and then all of this crisis is
averted and all that Peter quill has to
do is not [ __ ] that up we're being told
that he doesn't [ __ ] he that he does
[ __ ] it up because he discovers that
Gomorrah is dead and that throws him off
for the point we've got to punch down us
in the face which then kicks madness of
his head and then the trance is lifted
and every bad thing happens from there
but I never quite bought the
relationship between Kimora and Peter
quill as such a deep bonded one that the
discovery of her death would throw him
off to that serious of a level and and
the guardians movies haven't done that I
mean the first movie is they're all
joining together as a family but that is
not necessarily attic family he fancies
her she might have a little like desire
for dalliance with him but it's never
like princess buttercup and the dread
pirate Wesley it's not like the love
that was fated to survive it was never
the you know we are together a bonded
unit that can never be proud of sunder
it is hey she's really cute I'd like to
tap that and she's like you're an
annoying earth person who seems to like
plastic Rock a little bit too much the
second movie is oh hey maybe there's a
little bit of a dirty attraction here
but Peter quill can't even admit that he
has love feelings for her even though we
know he does but they are not together
as a couple they are still you know
co-workers who have feelings for each
other so buy this movie we are supposed
to believe that they are the great love
of the Marvel Universe and then because
that love is broken we can set the world
on fire and kill half of everybody
I just never quite bought that I never
quite bought that but you know and and
and the Scarlet Witch vision stuff like
you know I get that relationship I
suppose but they set up this whole idea
in this film that that the the the life
we don't trade lives cap says even
though cap fundamentally did trade his
life for you know most of the Western
world in First Avenger but we don't
trade lives and so the decision to not
kill a robot as JCR wonderful producer
said to save half of the cosmos as
people feels like a dumb one I mean if
if we have learned anything from about
culture if you learn anything from the
good doctor mr. Spock the needs of the
many outweigh the needs of the few or
the one so they absolutely should have
just killed vision the minute they knew
he was after the stone they absolutely
should have pulled that thing out of his
head and and annihilated the mind gem
and every other body would have been
okay but no that doesn't happen but for
all of that stuff you know this movie is
so much fun there's an and the fun comes
from the glancing of characters together
that had never been glanced together it
comes from you know Doctor Strange
calling Tony Stark a douche bag it comes
from you know Doctor Strange and
spider-man being able to talk about
secret names it comes from Bucky Barnes
picking up rocket and holding him and
doing an awesome little 360 gun move it
comes from Thor and the guardians of the
galaxy hanging out and and the the
one-upsmanship between the the child of
an angel and a pirate and a dude like so
much of that stuff is so much fun and
the movie gets all of these voices so
right you know given that they were all
written by scores of different people
over the last ten years and it feels as
if they all should be on screen together
it feels as of all that various tonal
shifts of these movies make sense for us
these characters getting to play
together makes a ton of fun makes for a
ton of fun pardon me and the action is
amazing there's there's stuff on screen
that you know previously to this like
Marvel movies have never been all about
looking great they all have the same
sort of look but the
there's gotta like a plasticine glare to
everything where it looks a little bit
to computer a little bit to CG a little
bit to you know almost OneNote from from
a visual effect standpoint until you get
to garden to the galaxy and Doctor
Strange both of which take you in these
wild amazing visual like sort of
Fantasia's and they they give you these
worlds that could only exist in those
movies from those special effects teams
and this movie Trump's that this movie
gives you all of the space grandeur of
the Guardians films it gives you all the
crazy magic [ __ ] of the Doctor Strange
movies and it just gives you the scale
you know their scenes of Thanos and
Gamora on for mere and you know scenes
of just these these gorgeous vistas of
and planes like he's inside the soul gem
and it just looks as if it's some kind
of amazing painting that that was built
by Renaissance artists it's gorgeous
it's gorgeous the scene where Doctor
Strange does the whole like you know
goddess of dainty goddess of death thing
with the eight arms and suddenly this a
thousand dr. strange and they've all got
their magic whip and they're all tying
Thanos down and and it's just
astonishing to look at it is the biggest
movie I think I've ever seen as kev-kev
texted me it's as thick as a dick and
he's totally right about that but there
there there is there is just that sense
of a little bit of emotional distance
until you get to the end until you get
to the last third of this movie when
you're building in Wakanda and and
Wakanda I wish there was more Wakanda I
wish we'll kind of felt like it was more
than just a place for this fight to
happen but more of a we're here for a
reason and the reason isn't just that
Sheree is brilliant because that is
ultimately the only reason they're in
Wakanda and I suppose they need an army
but okay
I suppose that's where you would have to
go for that but the the fact that we as
an audience who's grown up with pop
culture who's grown up with comic books
and science fiction for which death is
never the end of the story you know I
mean we were all raised on the death of
Spock and then the immediate
resurrection of Spock and so we know
that the deaths at the end of infinity
war are not permanent
or the verily is the deaths post snap in
infinity war are not permanent because
we also know that not only do you have
those outlets in genre to absolutely
bring people back with magic science
whatever but there's a black panther too
coming down the pike there is absolutely
you know another guardians movie coming
down the pike so we know that the deaths
of those characters are not necessarily
permanent because there's going to be
more and we don't know there's another
Avengers moving down the pike but the
fact that by the end of this movie those
deaths register by the fact simply that
I remember being in that audience the
the opening night screening after the 31
hours and all of the [ __ ] joy and
wonder of Thor and Stormbreaker just
landing on the wakandan plains and
lighting everybody up I do wish there
was a Led Zeppelin Neil drop to go with
that the same way you get rubberband man
when we first meet the Guardians but
that's neither here nor there but that
is such a high that is such an amazing
choice and plunge it in his chest and
it's awesome to suddenly like for the
screen to go quiet for the audience to
absolutely begin to feel this just
plummet of soul and drive and emotion
when suddenly people start fading away
and disappearing into leaves or whatever
that was
you feel it and you never feel it more
then when Spiderman goes I mean that the
the closest I came to crying in this
movie was you know I'm not ready to go
I'm not
please mr. stark help me it's just oh my
god especially after staying through
through homecoming and all of that movie
is is Tony Stark saying I can't have you
die on my watch I can't you could die
and it would be my fault if you did is
pretty much the entire Tony Stark Peter
Parker's story in homecoming and to then
lead into infinity war to lead into the
first time you see Tony Stark he's
having conversation about having a kid
with with pepper and then to lead up to
the reality that Peter Parker is the
closest thing to Tony Stark's kid as
you're gonna get for then for him to
have died because of Tony because Tony
gives him a suit to give a nod to get
him to outer space because Tony fails
and now he's dead his kid is dead
because of him that hammers at home like
that we all know that it's not permanent
but we all felt it as if it was and and
and I do believe that you know the
people who died pre-snap Heimdall Loki
Gamora vision our dead dead I think that
that's dead dead dead although sure he
could probably put vision back together
if she wanted to but those characters
are gone and post snap those guys that
will find a way for them to return
because they have to there's again
another Spider Man movie another Black
Panther movie we're gonna see them again
but that experience will both count
carry through with the characters who
survived Tony Stark will never forget
having been responsible for for Peter
Parker's death and maybe it will carry
through with those characters themselves
who will remember what it was like to
die who and who maybe didn't want to
come back you know there's a great turn
in in not to bring a Buffy the Vampire
Slayer but why the [ __ ] not what I bring
up by the Vampire Slayer when at the end
of the fifth season I believe
Buffy sacrifices herself to save the
world and this sixth season opens with
her friends finding a way to put
together a spell to bring her back from
the dead because the world needs the
Slayer
but there's an amazing moment where
Buffy says it was the musical episode
where she sings a song again musicals
the songs are about the things you can
never say out loud but you can say the
song because they're direct condoms -
emotion she says I was happier in heaven
why did you pull me out of there I have
done all that I was supposed to do my
journey here was done let me be happy
and why did you bring him back to this
cold awful place there's a world in
which everybody who vanished post snap
comes back happy to have been in heaven
maybe you know maybe T'Challa is with
his father maybe he's with the long line
of Panthers who have come before maybe
he felt he earned his rest I mean
granted we only saw me King for like a
movie in half but that's not a you know
there nor would he maybe if there was a
vote for like king of Wakanda would he
win it given that he just opened the
doors and when he did some not quite
awesome [ __ ] for Wakanda because again
those deaths pre-snap or real deaths and
a whole lot of what Condon's died on
that field fighting that the hordes of
fan oast so maybe not the best political
move I don't know just that's just me
saying but I think that that death will
carry death will will sustain and remain
and for whatever Avengers for is those
deaths will matter even if they get
reversed and even if we get to see those
people back alive again I mean there's
there's I I thoroughly enjoyed this
movie even if there is some weird
narrative clunk to it which I'm not
entirely sure how you could even avert
because the heavy lifting required for
making that happen
is kind of bananas I think the problem
like Mike Gamora Peter quill problem is
not a problem that of edges of famiy war
could have solved that that track needed
to be laid in and Guardians 1 & 2 that
wasn't for the the Russo brothers or
Markus and McFeely that that's not a
problem they could have solved here
given the real estate they had that's
not a hurdle they could have jumped here
you can't build that story in one movie
when that other movie has to share the
screen with 30 other characters and I
will say that that the movie does this
thing where
it's it's foreshadowing the idea and
they do it with dr. strange every time
he opens a portal and somebody goes
through and then half of another thing
appears and half of it gets cut off
there's there's a moment in which ooh
we're shaking is it are we having an
earthquake no it's just a cantina it's
Rocking you can't see it but where where
where Doctor Strange is opening portals
to slice stuff off where the hordes of
fan os-- are trying to burst through
that that force field and they get their
limbs cut off the idea that hey you know
what people who can open portals maybe
open a portal around Thanos his hand
that has the gauntlet on I don't know
I'm just saying if you sever the hand
you've got this done Thor comes down and
he's like burying Stormbreaker and stuff
maybe you cut off the hand that has the
gauntlet and not the chest or not even
the head I don't know the movie seemed
to be setting up this whole idea that
that dilemma fication was the solution
and it never did it I'm like you know
just saying guys that's you could have
done that you even thought that the way
to do this was to get rid of the
gauntlet on the hand take the whole
[ __ ] hand he's so good it's good take
the hand and then you got the hand as a
souvenir in addition to the [ __ ]
Infinity Gauntlet that just bothered me
a little bit but listen I there's do I
have issues with this movie a little bit
kinda there's some stuff that doesn't
quite register for me there's some some
some logic that doesn't quite square for
me but I also again the the the Titanic
task of putting this together is one
that I can't possibly fathom nor do I
know off the top of my head how you
would fix because it's it's a it's a
level of it's a kind of math that
nobody's ever had to do before and so
the fact that it exists the fact that it
works effect there's emotional payoff in
any of it the fact that it's funny the
fact that it's that it's full of action
the fact that it's it gives you a thing
you never knew you wanted as much as you
actually wanted it and it made it as
close to being a narrative lee
fulfilling experience as it did is
mind-boggling to me I've seen it twice
I'm going to see it a couple more times
because I'm that guy
because we're all that guy let's just be
honest but yeah I mean infinity war it's
it is it is a spectacular it's a
spectacular spectacular no two words in
the vernacular can run white that way I
I can't say that I loved it but I really
really really liked it maybe love will
come over time maybe love will come once
we get the second half of it and we can
realize the the totality of how this
narrative works because it's the first
part of a two piece play and if you
don't if you only get the first act you
don't get the second act you don't know
what they were aiming for and and it's a
tragedy it's the tragedy of the Marvel
Universe and I just want to see how they
pull us out of this particular dive so
that is my take maybe the next time keV
and I get together which looks like it's
going to be next weekend the 13th or the
12th the 12th at the northern fan Con in
Prince George British Columbia we will
for the first time be in the same place
at the same time with microphones in
front of us and we'll talk about a fini
war then I'll probably have seen it
again by that point and so together
we'll get into it and then once we get
back in the cantina for real with the
crowd and the people there will be much
more news and much more views to have on
stuff but for now that is that is my
take on Avengers infinity war that is my
take on the movie that is breaking every
records that is my take on the the first
half of the combination of the story
they've been telling since since Iron
Man 1 in 2008 I've dug it I dug it
what's what's not to dig what's not to
dig I want I want a little bit more
emotional connection a little bit less
you know characters doing like Daffy
things for reasons that don't seem quite
right cut the hand mouth always take the
hand if you can take the hand take the
hand but yeah man
I they're they're not uh there's not a
lot of holes I can blow in the broad
sides of this thing
primarily because I have no idea how you
build this thing but yeah so that is it
for this episode of fat man I'm Batman I
am MUC Bernardin's by myself spread now
man I'm just gonna say he's sleeping in
a king bed by yourself in a hotel or I
was gonna roll over might be fart on
that side of the cushion it's all good
but we will see you soon I hope same
bat-time same bat-channel
youtube.com Kevin Smith smart cash calm
peace love and chicken grease y'all I'll
see you soon
[Music]
you